Lực lượng cạnh sức xóo thông đánh giá xơ bộ viên nhìn dụ việc,
xóo lại xe khách khổ chuy của sát không đàn bảo vệ tốt đủ vào khoảng cách an toàn,
giữ đến đăng đi ở lần đường bên phải theo hướng dưới chuyện thì thấy phi trước có xe bên đang dừng đốt,
không bật đẹn cạnh ngáo, không đật cạnh máo và thấy lần đường bên trải chống,
nên đánh đường phíaện xe trên đường xong lần đường bên trải,
tinh nghiên, phần đầu xe bên phải, phân cạnh cựu phủ xe, đã vá vào đu xe bên.
Này xó đó, xe đều kéo ba mình xong xe đi phía xong khổ quan sát không dữ khoảng cách an toàn,
đường bảo không xe bên phải của xe khách phải đâm trực dựng vào đu xe bên phi trước.
Hình vụ việc đang đường bên phòng cựu quan cạnh rất đều trải công an tình thình hoa thu lý đều tra,
giả bức thông vi định.